what can we start with today
on raising daughters so we don't we
don't screw them up
i got a lot of controversial questions
there when i posted that um
link on the community tab there's a few
there that are that a lot of you guys
are going to want to hear about um
how old's your daughter now rolla she uh
just turned 23
last month okay and i got uh basically
12 going on 22 on my hands
um i really started to put like
when did you start to put a concerted
effort on making sure you
were doing something useful as a father
with a daughter like when did you come
to realize that i have a real
responsibility here not to screw this up
yeah i mean everybody asked me this
question it's like uh it's the the chris
rock uh the chris rock uh joke question
which is you know what do you do to keep
your baby off the pole
you know how do you how do you keep her
from being you know from being corrupted
by this society
and um from the very earliest ages
and like remember my daughter was born
in 1998
so she grew up during disney channel
right she grew up with
hannah montana she grew up with
when disney channel was actually
something that was like like
a high school musical right those are
like the early 2000s kind of so maybe
you don't know what i'm talking about
because you're your daughter's
just kind of getting into her tweens
right now i guess
um but when all that was going down i
was i just
tried to be uh to have fun with her when
she
when it was when she was really young
right um
and i didn't try to um
make her girly i didn't try to make her
more like a boy
i just kind of just let it go let it
sort of let the cards drop where they
will and she was already girly to begin
with
and um the best thing um
that i had going for me was that i had a
really strong marriage i still do have a
very strong marriage and my wife is very
involved with
with her because she always wanted a
daughter right she always wanted to have
a
daughter to sort of be best friends with
and she is she's really good friends
with
with as well as being her mother and um
uh my wife is probably more
disciplinarian than i am
i think but i think it's i think maybe
that that might be a father-daughter
thing
more than like me um you know being one
way or the other it's just like that
maybe that's the way it works out
uh i would say also um you have to
remember this and uh because i'm gonna
reference this probably throughout this
whole show is my brother
has a son who is about this just maybe
like six months younger
than my daughter so i i kind of
took some cues from how he was raising
his son and then
he has uh also another daughter so i
have a niece and a nephew
and his daughter is about like 18 or
well she's 19 now so she's so she's 18
19 years old my daughter is actually the
oldest and then
um my nephew who uh is maybe six months
younger than my daughter so i'm kind of
i'm growing up with this i'm i'm
learning about this and you have to also
have to remember that
when i was a younger father when i was
raising my daughter who was like see
between the ages of 0 and 10
i'm also in school and so
daddy's always going to to his classes
dad's doing a lot of work
i always had a lot of projects going um
i was playing a band at that time
i was also going to i was working 40
sometimes
50 hours a week and i was also going to
school part-time
to finish up my degree because i went
back to college
to finish up my degree my then then it
was a degree and then it was degrees
after that
um and so i had a lot going but i always
had weekends off and i think one of the
things that was
a little bit weird about my situation
was my wife worked weekends because
she's a medical professional so she's
working you know
kind of odd shifts so it wasn't anything
weird for her to just spend time with me
and just spend time with her mom and
then when we will all get together we'd
be a family we're only one we were like
a little family right i only have one
daughter
and so uh there was uh
i don't know if there was a concerted
effort or any kind of concern
for that in the early days it was when
she got to be 12
right once once they get to the tween
years and then they get into high school
that's when the chips are down and
that's when you kind of learn who
they're really going to be
and then that's when i was i think a
little bit more instrumental
um she was she was always been very
girly she still is very girly
um she uh she's a pageant competitor
pageant winner
um and she's very smart she's again
she's doing her post-graduate work right
now she's getting her master's degree so
she's very smart
in some ways uh probably better than me
at math
and i don't know how that happened but
um
i think a lot of it has to do with a
two-parent family first of all because
i'm a if you've read anything in my
third book which is positive masculinity
the first
third of that book is dedicated to red
pill parenting and there's an
entire chapter um in the first part of
that book called raising daughters
that's why i wanted to do this with you
yeah and uh that's so
i don't i was looking for a for a
picture that i took this weekend
when we went for a cruise with my
daughter i'm gonna text at you
just so you can see a recent to get an
idea but carry on i just i wish there
was some
like it would be very easy for me to
give you like some you know
checklist of here do this do this do
this but i think probably the
the basis is um there's there's a few
things that i mentioned in
in the uh in the third book i think the
most important one for most guys right
now is you got to be red pill aware to
to begin with and you've got to have a
strong marriage
if you want your if you want to raise a
strong strong independent daughter right
if you want to if you want to have a
daughter who
is resistant who is durable um
my my approach to parenting is has
always been
i'm not going i was really against
homeschooling in the beginning
my brother homeschooled his son and his
daughter for a while until they they
just
they got logistically it was just to too
much right
and i was very much against that and now
i've kind of softened to the idea i can
understand why
why parents would want to remove i think
for different reasons now but they would
want to remove their kids from
certainly a public education i don't
know about private but like certainly
public education
and want to want to educate them
themselves great now
now i'm on board back then i wasn't so
much but now i understand like
i understand um i think how the process
works a little bit better
so just for clarity's sake like
when did you actually come to the
realization like i have a proper job to
do here this is important
i don't want to screw this up like was
it when she was 12 you said when she
tweeted i i came to that conclusion a
lot earlier than that
and again this is uh this is me cause
like mine was when i was going through
my divorce
and oh my god like three like between
three and four and that's when the like
realization hit me like a frying pan of
the forehead and i'll tell you more
about that in a second right
when i was um when i was in college and
i was studying psychology uh part of my
basic you know education you know
psych 101 was you had to take child
psychology as a requirement
and at that time my daughter was about
three or four
maybe almost five at that point and
uh one thing i learned was that children
do not think in
abstract terms until really until
they're like in their 20s like their
your brain is not fully a human's brain
is not really fully developed until
you're about 20 21 years old at least
that's by popular you know neurological
science and everything yeah but um
certainly at three
four five years old uh children do not
think in abstract terms
uh i'll give you an example how that
works like have you and maybe you've had
this happen to you too
like if my daughter at that age really
loved macaroni and cheese right and so
you'd make you know like shells and
cheese or something like that or
whatever
and then you change things up right and
you get like uh
dinosaur uh shaped you know macaroni and
cheese and you and it's the same thing
right it's exactly it's pasta and it's
cheese right you say and they won't eat
it
and they're like that's not macaroni and
cheddar doesn't look like macaroni and
cheese it kind of smells a little bit
they won't eat
they won't eat it because the shape
looks a little bit different or it's
um if you if you pour the same amount of
liquid in a glass that's squat and you
pour another one that's in in a tall
glass
you want them they automatically think
that the tall glass has more right
because it's taller like it's more
there's got to be more volume it's not
it's actually the exact same but they
can't think in abstract terms like that
and that transfers into a lot of
different ways that how children learn
and that
that one class really taught me a lot
and if there's a point where i realize
i've got a job to do here it was
realizing that when a kid hits four or
five years old they're like sponges
and at that point right and i think this
is the probably one of the most sinister
like wrapping up the whole divorce
yeah yeah because they learn so much
during those those formative years
and that's when a woke society really
wants to guess especially
to daughters but also to to little boys
that's when they sort of indoctrinate
those little boys and we always talk
about how we
how we teach little boys as if they're
little girls yeah
it's almost this natural progression for
the female
gynocentric teachers to do that but
there's also
the flip side to that which is girls can
do anything girls can go
to the moon they can be president they
can do like look here hannah montana
secret superstar she could do anything
and it's always it's it's almost like
the extreme for boys is
you know settle down you know go go over
there if you can't learn like a girl
johnny go over in the corner over there
that's that's one side of the coin the
other flip side of the coin is
you need girls need to do everything
we're going to the museum and we're
going to
you know we're going to learn fine art
and we're going to learn sculpture and
now we're going to go learn pick up bugs
out of the garden or something like that
it's like this
everything is is day camp for the girls
where the boys are just like settle down
stop moving
like a girl talk about a girl and so
it was right then about three four five
years old that's when
little kids are like sponges and it was
right then that i noticed there was a
lot of like following around with
everything that i did
a lot of like soaking up a lot of
behavior and like day-to-day tasks
and i would start to involve her in a
lot of things like if i had a task to do
like assemble an inversion table
you know for example i'd be like hey you
know you want to help daddy put this
thing together and she'd be right into
it man
now it's like not even interested but
like three four five
right into it i've always been very
creative and so my daughter participated
in a lot of the same like the same
artistic
kind of stuff that i did she never
really want like she want to play drums
she still likes to kind of like play
my my drum set downstairs but that's
about it that's like i could have taught
her guitar there's a lot of things i can
teach her
but she always kind of leaned more
towards the creative side of things she
liked to draw and she liked to you know
do cutouts and things like that
and and that kind of relates into to uh
what she
you know which what she's like right now
but i think
probably the best aspect or the best
thing that taught my daughter is to
live out a masculine ideal with her
right to be like you know how
what gandhi says you'll be the change
you want to see in the world
you